[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Tuesday everyone so tonight we
pose a question should we kill all white
people
we interrupt Gutfeld for this breaking
news actor and comedian Wayne Brady has
come out as pansexual Brady is best
known for the sketch comedy show Whose
Line Is It Anyway and is the current
host of cbs's Let's Make a Deal he says
that while on a path to self-discovery
he didn't fully identify as bisexual
adding quote to me pan means being able
to be attracted to anyone who identifies
as gay straight bi transsexual or
non-binary we'll keep you updated on
this developing story now back to
Gutfeld
well that is something
so as I was saying should we kill all
white people
seems crazy but hear this man out the
man jumping up and down is Julius malema
at a rally for a South African political
party called the economic freedom
fighters malima LED nearly 100 000
people in this chant
foreign
[Applause]
kill the boar
that's spelled b-o-e-r at first I
thought they meant b-o-r-e and I thought
what do they have against this guy
I mean I get it but then I thought it
was the animal b-o-a-r and I thought it
was an attack on this
but no kill the boar is actually a song
dating back to the fight against South
Africa's racist apartheid system which
ended in the early 90s the boar in the
song are white South African farmers of
European descent we call them white
people here are some examples
now he's talking about killing white
people now I mean if I were Tom shallou
I'd be canceling that gig in Cape Town
ASAP obviously saying kill the white
people is pretty bad at a political
rally and it really tanked when I said
it as one lucky guy I'm outnumbered
but he even did a little machine gun
sound so you don't think he meant kill
them with kindness here's South African
Elon Musk tweeting about it quote they
are openly pushing for genocide of white
people in South Africa then he asked
South Africans president why do you say
nothing but then Molina later shot back
not literally anyway
I will sing this song as in when I feel
like
it's not my song It's a struggle song
why must I educate alien mask he looks
like an illiterate the only thing that
protect him is his white skin oh that's
exactly what you should say when you're
trying to prove you're not racist right
must white skin protects him but from
what certainly not UV rays he's so pasty
he makes Gwyneth Paltrow look like
Serena Williams damn I know
damn and you just got done talking about
killing whites so I think you mean
bullets actually kill the boar is
literally precise an example of a few
figurative phrase however would be these
wool thongs are killing me and they do
believe me
of course when Elon Musk says something
liberals must oppose it if they were
lost in the desert and he brought water
they'd complain it was in a plastic
bottle so Molina is getting plenty of
help from American journalists who hate
white people almost as much as he does
even though most of them are wider than
a mayonnaise sandwich according to the
New York Times despite the words the
song should not be taken as a literal
call to violence according to Mr Molina
and Veterans and historians of the
anti-apartheid struggle it's been around
for decades one of many battle cries of
the anti-apartheid movement that remain
a defining feature of the country's
political culture end quote but other
defining features of South Africa
include some of the world's highest
rates of murder assault and robbery take
that Chicago South Africa probably has
better pizza too
but did you catch that at the top
despite the words don't you just love it
Libs will assume the worst possible
interpretation of anything you or I will
say but kill white people isn't supposed
to be taken literally the people who say
Law and Order is a dog whistle who
invented microaggressions and Trigger
warnings now give white people kill
white people a pass that makes as much
sense as Kamala Harris talking about
talking to kids about space
despite the words if someone chanced
three words and one of them is kill run
for your life if you're wondering what
does he mean by that you're a a
soon to be dead so the song
apparently isn't racist because you know
it's been around for a long time how
exactly does that work does that go for
Dixie 2 or Cotton-Eyed Joe or Jimmy
Crack Corn even an old song Can Inspire
homicide the times also says malima
quote thrives on provocation apparently
the line between provocation and hate
speech is as funny as Sarah Silverman's
armpits
but holy leave the target however of
course is someone they hate keep in mind
the media accused Jason Aldean of racism
for warning rioters and looters not to
try that in a small town he wasn't the
one saying black people are all violent
criminals though his critics made that
assumption a lot of the antifa rioters
are skinny whites I thought of joining
them just to lose a few pounds
also Luke Combs was accused of racism
for doing a cover of a black woman's
song from the 80s how dare he be a Tracy
Chapman fan doesn't he know that he's
white
so the media claims innocuous statements
are racist dog whistles yet advocating
the death of One race that gets a pass
apparently everything's racist except
for singing about killing whites it
explains why some riots are mostly
peaceful when dozens die and others are
insurrections in which the only person
killed is an unarmed insurrectionist
so once again it's the idea that when we
only see groups we exempt total groups
from behavior that we demand from others
individuals kill the boers accept it try
that in a small town racist George Floyd
riots accepted January 6 worst thing
ever 7-Eleven clear clobbering a thief
arrest violent mobs and cities except
and don't call them violent mobs that's
offensive to Violent mobs and future
Democrat voters
so what's the lesson if the left
believes racism only applies to groups
of people they don't like then the only
racism that exists is theirs and the
race of the racism they accuse others of
is just a tool they use that the media
happily empowers because when you think
about it they can't really see racism
because if they did they'd have to
remove every damn mirror in their house
let's welcome tonight guess
Douglas more like Doug Moore because we
can't get enough of other unboxings
Douglas Murray
Michigan needed this Dixon to do a whole
lot of fixing former Michigan
gubernatorial candidate tutor Dixon
she avoids Thanksgiving because they use
her arms as the wishbone Fox News
contributor got tips
and he wears a pyramid as a party hat my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Tyrus I go to you first for no apparent
reason whatsoever because I was the only
person who cheered when you said kill
whitey yes
oh it really isn't about South Africa it
is about the New York Times it's not
even about that
it's like a science experience
experiment for me every time you have
the guts to talk about racism versus
white people because I get offended but
if you won't get offended I'm not going
to help you anymore and that like when
you said it yeah every white person in
there acted like they deserved it well
maybe we did something I don't know they
don't you never say no hell no don't
talk about me like that yeah I'm a good
person you guys never do that we do that
if someone says someone like damn that
was racist no I don't want my coffee
anymore you know what just give me my
damn coffee you working and I'll leave
you guys don't defend yourselves and
that's the problem that's why a guy can
go on stage and chant what he chanted
forever and get everyone to do it with
no no consequences no canceling there's
no because there's no white people
willing to defend you've got to stand up
for yourselves and not accept it and you
also got to be able to laugh you have to
be able to laugh at this stupid they did
not laugh they did not laugh because
they were scared they were like this is
a serious topic no what they were doing
this
someone laugh first I really want to
laugh but I don't want to be the first
you don't want to be the first white
person to laugh yeah it's like watching
National Geographic where the wildebeest
like the first one to cross the water
everyone knows is going to get eaten but
they have to get across or they'll die
so everyone's just like you go you go
and then when he gets here like oh oh I
always forget about that I always forget
when I do these monologues that it
always is going to happen it pops the
hell out of me I'm laughing and giggling
and you'll watch me watch the crowd
trying to find who's gonna be the one
young lady right there
still Douglas uh this is really
interesting because the New York Times
if you wear a red hat that would be a
dog whistle but actually saying kill
whitey come on give him a break yeah as
I always say about the dog whistle
nonsense if you if you hear the whistle
you are the dog they never take that
into account yes what does it exactly
you think you're hearing but yeah the
New York Times hears racism everywhere
except for when it's really there like
in cases like this it's an amazing thing
this but this goes to show something
I've often said about America as well
which is whenever a politician goes on
about racism just look at what else is
happening in their area and you can be
guaranteed there's a like terrible
education standards horrible Health Care
standards and so on it's the same with
this South Africa's been entirely black
run for 30 years it's got devastating
crime it's got appalling uh just the the
power just goes off in the city like
Johannesburg all the time so that would
be the sort of thing that you would
think they need to sort out but no of
course they can always say let's just
kill the remaining white farmers and by
the way some people do so it actually is
an incitement of violence the best thing
about this story though is that guy
saying that guy Elon Musk then like look
at me he looks like an illiterate yes I
know there's a lot of things that people
do say about Elon Musk I've never heard
anyone say he's really so stupid he
can't even read you know I I think is he
doing that money though he's good with
numbers yeah he's doing numbers he's
trying to get to Mars it's quite a lot
he can do it seems to me so yeah
tutor there was a lot they were saying
some stuff about like you know it's the
excuse was it was from a long time ago I
get it but even in America we like we
cancel stuff because there were like
inappropriate for just five years ago I
for one cannot listen to the song
Christine 16 by KISS without feeling a
little dirty
there is no a long time ago in America
but this is the this is liberal
privilege at its best because the New
York Times comes out and they say look
away this is not what you think it is
and Elon Musk says you got to boycott
the New York Times because they are
they're crazy they're out there safe
They are promoting this this is exactly
what happens when Americans think every
other country is just like America
because they don't realize that South
Africa is actually has the third most
homicides in the entire world this is a
very dangerous country Elon Musk knows
that so he may not be able to read but
he lived there so he has some experience
understanding what it's like to be in
danger all the time yeah yeah you know
Kat I felt like this is proof that like
I would say 98 of the accusations of
racism are false because they're only
used against people you don't like that
it's like you can't take these people
seriously if they hold back now well
what I thought was interesting is that I
am not an expert on race and in South
Africa and guess what most people aren't
yeah and the way the New York Times
wrote this article was like experts say
this experts say this experts say this
where the uh while the far right jumped
on it yes and said that kill all white
people means they want to kill all white
people and I'm just like do you ever
talk to any regular people and see how
maybe you might think that yes uh it
doesn't have to be a far right thing
yeah I think that if you talk to only
experts all the time then you don't get
the perspective of the 98 of people who
are not academics or experts we're just
like people scrolling their phone on the
toilet like what is that yeah and I do
love the fact that like in in but
basically in all media every most people
don't know anything in media until they
look it up and then they act like they
knew it oh yeah you didn't know this I
was probably just not supposed to admit
that I have no idea you might not know
this history of South Africa but when
you like something or believe in
something so much to where you're going
to chant it yeah okay it means you've
made up your mind and you've committed
to what I'm about to say is so great
Kill Whitey is so powerful even the
specific group ones who Farm yeah kill
all the white people who Farm say it
with me say it together for the next 20
minutes I may not be able to read like
Elon Musk but I can read the room and if
I was a white farmer my ass would be up
out of there yeah
foreign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else